peu
si cet os mobile vous les connaissez
puisque vous les avez vous au salon de
l'automobile et puis vous les reverrai
au prochain salon de genève qui va
s'ouvrir dans quelques jours ce sont les
alpines l'alpine jean rédelé des
animateurs de la de la marque
c'est un peu une grande aventure parce
que au départ c'étaient des petits
quatre chevaux c'étaient les mécaniques
des petites quatre chevaux qui est au
départ des animés par un moteur de dix
sept chevaux les techniciens de renault
ont conçu quelque chose de remarquable
et nous arrivons de ce moteur maintenant
attirer près de 70 chevaux avec les
moteurs de compétition c'est à dire
qu'est ce que vous a donné l'idée au
départ de penser que à partir d'une
petite mécanique comme celle de la quête
chevaux on pouvait tirer une une voiture
de sport rapide
ce sont les courses que j'ai fait au
volant des quatre chevaux je me suis
rendu compte que les qualités de la
voiture permettait avec un habillage
différent de faire une voiture de sport
qui pouvait rivaliser avec les
meilleures voitures qu'il est offerte
sur le marché
alors là sont deux des modèles
commerciaux les voitures de compétition
on en reparlera un autre jour dès que on
s'arrête un peu plus particulièrement
sur celle ci maintenant évidemment les
alpines ont suivi l'évolution des
renault c'est à dire que au départ oui
moteurs quatre chevaux mais il ya le
moteur dauphine gordini mme greene
continuer
quels sont les les transformations que
vous apportez à la fois sur le plan
mécanique sur le plan de la suspension
sur le plan du freinage pour avoir celle
ci est bien très franchement nous
limitons les transformations au strict
minimum car les pièces qui nous sont
fournis par renault nous donne
satisfaction pour l'heure quasi totalité
nous aménageons sur le modèle 40 chevaux
la suspension en réglant la hauteur
d'une façon convenable en tenant compte
de l'allègement de notre voiture qui est
fait en matière plastique et tout le
reste pas de mécanique est pratiquement
d'origine freinage également oui ce qui
permet freinage nous avons choisi les
freins de renault qui sont les plus
largement dimensionnés et malgré
l'augmentation de vitesse ses freins
donné entière satisfaction
bon mais alors il ya évidemment ce
nombre de modifications apportées au
moteur oui allez jeter un coup d'oeil ça
c'est le moteur 40 chevaux c'est à dire
le moteur dauphine gordini normal
dominique gardy nigon normal alors on
nous apprend à parler tout le monde le
connaît puisqu'il est solide et donc
leur dîner mais alors lorsqu'un client
désire sur le modèle là le moteur qui
développe 70 ch qu'est-ce que vous
faites en transformant alors vous me
parlez vous voulez que je vous parle du
moteur de professeurs alors ce moteur
extérieurement se présente comme celui
ci à l'exception du collecteur
d'admission et d'échappement et du
carburateur
mais l'intérieur est considérablement
modifiées nous améliorons les
remplissages
de son remplissage par un des passages
plus grand dans les culasses par des
soupapes de plus grand diamètre par un
arbre à cames différents et nous
augmentons l'alésage du moteur en
surdimensionnant éventuellement
certaines pièces c'est à dire c'est un
travail de très grandes finition très
soignée
oui c'est un travail de compétition même
titre que les marques qui courent
font lorsqu'ils ont des moteurs de
compétition pas pareil nos services nous
suivons la même loi que les autres et ça
donne 30 chevaux de plus nous avons 30
chevaux oui bien écouter on va toujours
essayer sur ce petit moteur la wii est
serré bon ben on va essayer tout ça
maintenant un local et nos vies
[Musique]
on va
donc sur le circuit routier de monde et
qui nous sert de champ d'exercice pour
ses essais et qu'il va nous permettre de
juger principalement du comportement de
la tenue de route de la voiture mopar
enfin quand même rappeler ses
caractéristiques en ce qui concerne sa
vitesse et la vitesse avec ce montage
est de 145 km heure et les
intermédiaires d'intermédiaires 70 ans
2e environ et 110 103 kg est bon nous
approchons maintenant de la cuvette
vous dites que la voiture tient
parfaitement la route c'est un des
points on va pouvoir juger un je vous en
prie je dois dire qu'on est pour le
moment à 120 kilomètres à l'heure parce
que la voiture n'est pas débridé
on ne va pas la matraque et on ne va pas
d'accoucher à 140 km à l'heure on arrive
là dans la cuvette et condescendant à
110 ou troisième tour quand même d'une
manière générale on est
celui du silence que soit celui de la
plus drôle milliards dans les abris des
problèmes continus
[Musique]